[Music]
what action
hey guys I'll connect out the record
where we talk about whatever we want and
Joe likes interest whatever we want
what are you been up to full I've been
freaking living in China damn near why
why I just got my tan of you sound so
excited why straight up dance right now
over in China is huge it's freaking a
huge hype right now and it's just a just
giant wave and they have way more
[ __ ] money than the west coast and
over here no matter what in the industry
no matter what the King just can never
get past the fact that that's like Asia
group of guys you can never look past
that because like any client any
whatever any demographic anyone or
whatever you are called the King just
dies right you kind of and then you guys
know nothing it holds us down here I'm
just saying when you go over there it's
like the floodgates are unlocked
instead they pedestal all they do is
focus on the eight with sinners yeah
yeah when you're winded when you do
dance interviews so what's it like being
[ __ ] Asian like it's like Asian stuff
that's all they focus on over here
interesting I thought kynges or Korean
ninjas for the long time but then I
realized when I talk a lot of you guys
aren't Korean so I don't understand how
that made sense family ken that makes so
much more sense yeah it's okay
honestly I'm down for it to me whatever
the [ __ ] it means to anybody as long as
it's a good thing so in China Daigle
what's Kinjo know they don't even say
what's so must suck enjoy honestly they
just they just pass like a proper noun
like they probably don't even look into
the meaning of all they so all they care
about is I let your move
teach me precisely out there right now
we have to our partner specifically has
for and including ours and there's
definitely room for more expansion but I
think I think right now there's such
like um in terms of like actual dance
culture and stuff even though they're
like really really hype right now the
West Coast and everything that we have
over here is like what progresses the
artistry in the culture
and over there there are years behind of
like where we are not necessarily bad
with with just development so they're
doing this where they're at with dance
not decades behind just a couple years
behind that's so interesting cuz like a
pup is such it like like originated east
coast so much but there's so much dance
that started like started developing and
progressing in the west coast and it's
so [ __ ] fascinating like when I
started seeing people like like gig like
which is a specific like Bay Area thing
and I started seeing the East Coast I
should threw me off dude you know what I
mean because that was specifically a kid
to like Bay Area [ __ ] it's a social
media like generation though you know
what I mean like being able to like have
I mean freaking four nicely ensued but
by the homie did the Millie rock because
like of how much a trend can like go
beyond somebody's just like original
intention yeah it's like how every
nobody like kids nowadays don't know
what the original Harlem shake is yeah
and that it's it's nobody's fault it's
just that we live in a time where like
anything that can get put on a tattoo
can you put on line and get this
everywhere in the wrong context to
people receive in the wrong context
exactly so I think the crazy thing about
us going over there a lot is also we're
in a time frame where it's blowing up
regardless of our input and if we're
over there in a weird way and not to be
self-righteous or anything like that but
like it's almost anonymous to the idea
of like like Crusades back in the day
you would have to like physically go out
on missions to different places to kind
of spread share and teach your culture
and knowledge and philosophy in order
for people to really understand it for
what it is otherwise just they're
getting this wrong tech the context
aversion just you know this version of
artistry and like what it means
rocking supreme and everyone what the
[ __ ] that always yeah everybody out
there has all the hype and like so
little people have the actual swag out
well that's the hard part about dance
right I think like from what you know
just because I grew up with such a huge
dance community I'll see a lot of like
because I grew up with like you know
felt I AG and all that right and you see
like people back I feel like a lot of
like the older dancers they have a very
unique identity to the way they dance
you know what I mean so if you see like
filled dance and you see his choreo
you're like oh [ __ ] that's some philsed
like even when he was dancing for like
Bruno and he was choreographing all that
stuff I didn't know Phil was doing that
I like yellow how come brew dances like
Bill you know immediately boom and then
you just see it on all this social media
stuff
Oh
let's fill in the bed you know I feel
like a lot of the times to just with any
artistry not just dance a lot of the
times like what happens is people who
wanted spider Jack a lot of people but
you don't got that stake and that's the
that's that big difference like there's
people who could do moose but I doesn't
mean listen you could dance Bach just
that's that's the crazy thing nowadays
with with even the game in general
because everything's so shareable and
you can get influenced by anybody like
immediately everyone's good now yeah
everyone's good everybody knows that a
rip beats everybody's like talented
enough to have like this really
articulate texture dynamic to express
sounds in a bunch of crazy ways but like
now everyone's good and now we're back
to kind of like this grounds you're like
who stands out yeah you've seen Russian
twerk teams
I love cultural adoptions her name is
Farley it's crazy cause like it's hella
sexual but then its technical its tech
yes very technical its I saw this one it
was the most bizarre thing we're like
it's like a dance
like exhibition competition at a family
show and there's just girls [ __ ]
working and like doing handstands
Tork it and there's just like kids and
family members and everyone's just
watching and I'm like this is [ __ ]
crazy cuz out there it's maybe it's just
an art form or something you know I mean
it is it is still here but it's just the
context it was so bizarre man it's kind
of cool though just because like when
when the artistry gets elevated like
that you've got to put that much more
work to be right up here yeah yes the
game is totally different now and that's
that thing where people talk about swag
that's what you'll see it you know I
mean it's like oh you could do all my
moves but you don't got something here
that puts you right up here you know
like I'll see it like I have a friend of
mine right now
every time I see a [ __ ] and people are
trying to do his choreo like we think we
had a conversation about us like well
how do you who do you feel does come
into your class and kills them mostly
goes to be honest with you almost
everybody can do my moves
but there's something that they're
missing always and it's just their
technique is perfect but they just don't
have this thing they can do my I guess
like how he described it was just
because you like death doesn't mean that
you're a dancer so it's kind of like
just because you like the sing doesn't
mean you're a singer you know and that's
the same concept with any other type of
called heart yes soul I got
I got a lot of heart no technique it's
like the authenticity right imagine
imagine somebody like Kendrick if he
wasn't like born in content and didn't
have like a heart ring and was rapping
about that stuff and he still sounded
sick but you'd be like wait a minute
something you've smelled that yeah it's
not authentic and there's this is kind
of really invisible human connection
that people have when you can like feel
somebody's authenticity yeah one of my
favorite pretenders is Tupac he made
this [ __ ] feel authentic s food he's a
freaking artist man he knows how to
embody that [ __ ] cuz she's fat no cuz
she ain't home without she would only
pick songs that she felt a connection to
and so that's what that's why I like
when I see a lot of like you know
YouTube people sing and stuff there's a
lot of people who could technically sing
you know but there's there's a reason
why it doesn't really draw anybody to
their music being that's why a lot of
people forget music there's a lot of
forgettable music now but when you hear
something that's really [ __ ] good it
just kind of sticks with ya it's sharp
like a knife yeah you don't know what it
is it's that invisible thing that you're
talking did you hear about the whole uh
king of R&B thing yeah yeah so what's
his name Jack heads or something like
that I had never heard of him until this
beef thing but only this dude I think
that's a yeah he's just on IG and he
literally just claims that he's the king
of arms he claimed yeah wow that's crazy
I recently saw a P Diddy making a videos
he did responding to it I didn't haven't
even heard his music oh but he did he's
like well you know what he made a lot of
great points but at the end of it all he
was like we have to actually make army
to claim to be the king of art because
he's like no one's making her envy these
days yeah nobody's making order be like
are be would you ask a young kid with
R&B is they'll say Drake and Drake is
not a [ __ ] or anything
drinks on me cuz this music very sinks
on oh and so they're like I mean a lot
of people I disagree they're like oh I
don't think that I thought Beiber
the last R&B guy to be honest yeah he
was a ha was a technical like well yeah
it's rhythm and blues but yeah there's a
structure to it which makes it RMB feel
like jazz you're right same type of [ __ ]
yeah it all original that's why the 90s
R&B and even like in the past with the
80s or whatever like or even if you go
way before rhythm and blues like 50s
that [ __ ] Motown stuff all the way to
the 90s the structure is still the same
the style is different you know there's
people who are who are kind of taking
our beat to their own like type of genre
right not like Bryson tiller like heath
rise until it has he's doing his RB but
even then he's not really our and
because he's not really seen all his dog
division
you know division is our beat he's about
his first album the second I was a
little bit weaker right these
[ __ ] down yes and some good
freakin love making music d.v.d BSN we
done everything right now is just our
way though there's no booze nope they're
not really sad my army to me is so dope
just because like if you really like RB
there's like so much work that goes
behind it people don't even know like
just doing like vocal harmonies and
stats is so [ __ ] difficult because
you're using your voice is an instrument
you're stacking [ __ ] like eight
vocals together that's yours and you're
just making it it's so [ __ ] wild
dramatizing with yourself it's [ __ ]
amazing man and I kind of Miss that I
wish like some of these people who like
RB would still be current with the times
now and because you could do great like
division I think division does a great
job I think the production of the beats
monk you feel like a good song or sound
for today's generation but then like the
flow and then the way that he's seeing
it makes you especially for a 90's kid
go like this is some good army yeah it's
good RB and it just makes me like great
production because I think like 90s R&B
back in the day it was a lot about
showing off your vocals but now you
could ease off like evil ease off that a
little bit and rely have some of the
production to kind of get you there to
get that emotional ooh
so imagine boys two men came back as
like men to grandpa's and the EDM you
did a collab with [ __ ] what's his name
Bieber
I mean he's had that but that was in the
past Shawn Mendes national - another
dude Charlie puth I think so yeah
Charlie puth and that was like I'm like
why is Charlie puth
PU th yes I know
why is guy on this track I'm like let's
get and I like Charlie put pooch uh but
yeah like he they still sound exactly
how they did in the 90s and I'm like bog
man jeez it's so sad that they're
getting older they're [ __ ] in my
personal opinion you know who's like
really killing it who's the king arm
being you're [ __ ] a Barbie do I think
females are killing in the army right
now
females are killing it ha fucking's by
even Sabrina Claudio [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
like I feel like women are [ __ ]
smashing on this so back in the day I
used to really like just a lot of like
many singers Sabrina cause these [ __ ]
women are killing it dude and there's
like a texture flexibly if you listen to
Sabrina Claudia the texture to her voice
is amazing she doesn't have to like belt
but the way she like controls her voice
and adds a lot of like huskiness and
it's just so thick and full i [ __ ]
love her voice dude like have a [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] repeat last time this is
cool but I saw her alive alive I didn't
realize she wasn't that good but I loved
the music though John John Legend
commented on the he tweeted on that same
statement to saying pretty much the same
like you know there's a lot of people
doing some cool stuff but like right now
he would say that there is no king of
R&B like nobody's in the game like that
I love John Lennon so John Legend such
an OG to me man
just because even the way he sings isn't
very I say current yeah I mean he sings
very much from his like stomach it's not
from his nose and his throat which is
like really sings like him nobody else
seems like him so that's what makes it
authentic
yeah for sure so any it's weird because
he could like filter in between like an
OG way of singing and the new style -
depending on the production that's built
around him but like John Legend's an OG
- and I [ __ ] love [ __ ] I think it's
gonna be difficult to go back to the
days of like subcultures and uniqueness
to the point where there was an
underground scene for things and like a
distinct sound or look for a region or a
group of people because being global and
connected online everyone's adopting
everything yeah like you see immediately
if there's a brand new style and Georgia
company or
something kids in LA kids in Beijing
whatever they see it they go that's dope
I'm gonna start wearing my hat that way
or I'm gonna start adding this sound to
my music and it's it could be a European
EDM DJ or whatever yeah and everything
is turning into this like quick way of
adoption we're back in the 90s even like
it took forever and Asia was always
thirty years because like there was a
Rocksteady
Tokio back in a day like and they were
doing b-boys [ __ ] and they were teamed
up with like a rock steady crew and and
all that but it's like it was they were
so big and so separately doing windmills
and [ __ ] and then BOOM early 2000s they
have the b-boy competition in Korea and
they're changing the game where Asia
used to always adopt what they were
doing out here in the West Korea was
leading the b-boy type of stuff and it's
like if like things are changing dude
the other day I just I just watched
what's the cause it was last year's
freestyle session right and I've been
seen a bunch of like b-boy battles in a
minute I can't even comprehend what's
going on dude it's a volleyball so much
is the Olympics now like yeah what the
[ __ ] this is the first year that Junior
Olympics brought in breakdancing and
it's some like Russian kid it was the
first time which means I like it because
it's on that bird that for like b-boy
pocket from Korea that fools [ __ ]
crazy deaf wild Korea actually it's
funny that you mentioned that in terms
of like you know early two-thousands
Korean being the one that kill the game
but even better the year this year
Koreans jinjo crew is the one that like
took everything as well and same thing
it's just kind of like like I was
talking about it's almost like
everyone's good now it's almost like the
world has become a melting yeah that
like in personally I feel like an
optimistic in a good way we're gonna
start seeing more people to develop
identities because everyone's good now
so like you're talking about if you want
to be above the game now you got to do
so much more you have to innovate so
much harder because everyone is privy to
everything else mean yeah yeah yeah you
know all the originators like um you
know like the electric boogaloos and
stuff like no one knows who they are but
everyone's doing their moves yeah no one
100% unless you're in dance are like you
you're in the 90s or whatever like you
don't know who they are but everyone's
doing those moves so you can still see
like OG poppin in Japan dude that's why
I love Japan
they pay so much I spend to like like
Pascal on GOG they're [ __ ] dope man
like I love watching like Japanese
people pop dude it's like this it's a
clean style yeah like the lockers out
there just in from a different world
same with French lockers those guys are
[ __ ] dope it's just very authentic I
think that's what it really comes down
to you in cuz it is crazy how non
Americans are keeping it authentic
anybody can technically acquire with the
right amount of like passion dedication
and work ethic right but when it comes
to that authenticity with that very
clear line of like I am about this I
[ __ ] love this you can sense that
yeah sure you could sense it in anything
but isn't it crazy though how that [ __ ]
is from Fresno or like LA California all
the body all that stuff right but who's
keeping it alive Europeans and Japanese
that's you know what I mean like no one
here's really doing that [ __ ] do you
talk about like a R&B dude [ __ ] UK
people with RB is [ __ ] wild dude
they've they've they kept it oh gee and
they've almost like elevated in my purse
oh you mean like new soul like yeah you
mean Winehouse a amazing dude it's
called like Neil's so-and-so like that
yeah that's that's what blows my mind is
like damn dude like it's kind of cool
like when things are global like that
like they have their own interpretation
of something like that and they preserve
that sound you just listen to any
[ __ ] Jessie J's like live recordings
Jesse oh god dude I [ __ ] love Jessie
J dude on [ __ ] real like if I could
have a voice to sing light and in the
male version I would want Jessie J her
clean runs her control how much she belt
it's [ __ ] wild ooh it she's even
better live than she is over her
recordings cuz she could actually like
do what she want I don't stank - it's
like Brian midnight
Brian midnight sounds better live than
he does on recording cuz there's like a
power to like the live essence there's
almost this thrilling feeling especially
as another human knowing that somebody's
doing something that is unique to that
moment oh for sure it's especially if
you memorize like a Brian McKnight song
or anything a song that you love off the
album and then you go to the concert and
then they do it slightly different and
the variation is obviously in higher
performance caliber so you're just like
gorgeous
you know they mean just yeah I thought
out green and then there were grannies
throwing panties out of them and I was
like [ __ ] and you know what's crazy his
voice sounded better that it's older now
and like for some reason I would think
that would it would be worse but it
sounds better to me especially was
flicking the sweat at those women they
were drinking it yeah man the ground was
sitting next to me she was at the Walker
but when her song came on she [ __ ]
used all of her last remaining energy to
stand up it took her like five minutes
to get up what she's like it's my song
she finally yeah she finally got up oh I
was like damn dude this is that's why
man I was like YouTube that I seen a lot
of people who who are on YouTube before
they you know they Melodyne in the
auto-tune you hear them live it is
straight trash it's like I had no idea
you could not sing yeah like you can't
you actually cannot see or you're just
like wow I'm really impressed with what
you've been able to do with your
terrible voice I've seen it and it's
like it's almost shocking dude I also
think it's the sign of the times though
like we're gonna use and rely on
technology to create stuff versus taking
and our standards are very different
from you know people that are their
fanbase but then as time goes like for
example when hip-hop first came out
everybody thought that was some gimmicky
[ __ ] and they were like you're just
thieving beats from all these other
artists that worked really hard on their
music yeah we didn't know that these
songs exist such like a societal like
vicious cycle though because if it's not
that then it's the next soul culture but
then what I notice is when I started
getting into music production and then I
started learning about music more and I
started hearing the original artists I
started liking the original artists more
than
you know sampled musician producers that
made the beats but I can it what it is
that's that's that invisible line of
like authenticity of when something
comes from a place of just like honest
origin they're just this it's a classic
it stands the test of time yeah it's
like Jeff Buckley singing hallelujah and
knowing that he like died young yeah so
when you hear it suddenly the gasoline
is about it is like even more chilling
than hearing anybody else's rendition
even if it like in your opinion sounds
bad because like there's something
connected to it that's more powerful
than just the sound just the technical
performance or whatever like every year
stands the test of time happy birthday
[ __ ] feels great when you see that
[ __ ] my favourite garlis of a language a
is how everybody starts in the highest
key ever and they don't think about the
[ __ ] crescendo look how high the bass
that's already happy birthday to you
happy everybody goes off-key at that
point cuz you have to go in octave
[Laughter]
[Music]